الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن ان يصبح قاتلا
متوحشا ويقضي على البشر تحذيرات عديده تدق
ناقوس الخطر قبل فوات الاوان وفق تقرير
صحيفه التي كشفت وكشف فيهم بان مسؤولين
بريطانيين طالبوا بضروره تنظيم منتجي
ومنتجي ومطوري الذكاء الاصطناعي على نطاق
عالمي وخلق انظمه قويه جدا تمكن الجميع من
السيطره على هذه التقنيه الجديده اما
المدير التنفيذي للشركه فعاد وكرر موقفه
السابق بانه خائف من الذكاء الاصطناعي
التوليدي الذي ساهم بتطويره قبل ايام اعلن
مستشار رئيس الوزراء البريطاني لشؤونه
التكنولوجيا بان الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن ان
يصبح قويا بما يكفي لقتل العديد من البشر
في غضون عامين فقط
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات